thank you for joining us here at simply
learned today my name is Orion stalard
and one of the staff members here I also
am a data analyst and a project manager
and primarily financial services
currently I'm with with Bank of America
in their corporate headquarters in the
southeastern United States Charlotte
North Carolina and we're gonna be
talking about are the what I would argue
is probably the the one of the top data
science languages that you'll be able to
use to get yourself launched into an
exciting and rewarding career in data
science and that would be the case at
whatever level it is that you you're
looking to aspire to whether you want go
purely to science if you want to use it
in a business application if you want to
launch your own company any of those are
possible with with our programming and
so what we're gonna do is I'm going to
give you a quick background and then
we're gonna do a high-level overview so
that you can understand the basic
functionality and be prepared to quickly
use our for your own purposes whatever
those purposes are so to begin a little
background just to give you a sense of
where our came from this is a
programming language that launched in
1993 a couple of professors at the
University of Auckland built this for
originally for their students and it got
such great feedback that that they've
decided to take it further and make it
into an open-source programming language
which are continues to be so
open source means that unlike some of
the other languages out there this is
something that you can access for free
and with a resource such as simply learn
and some of the other free online
resources that I'm going to talk to you
about you'll be able to get all of the
information that you need for you know
very cost cost you know
inexpensive way let's say so the beauty
of our also is in my opinion you don't
need a degree in computer science to
understand you don't need four years of
programming to understand you can by the
end of this lesson you'll be able to
jump in with both feet and and start
doing things writing basic programs in
arm so with that this is a brief again
high-level walkthrough and we're going
to start with and these are the things
that you'll you'll know by the time
we're done here in just a few minutes
the four types of operators the
different types of conditional
statements the loops that are used in
our commands that you can use to run our
scripts and commonly used our functions
are is what you would call if you are a
computer programming background person
if you've been when you know working in
Java or if you've been working in Python
or any of the other languages out there
c-plus you've probably heard of what's
called a Turing complete language which
is a classic definition of what a
computer language is to be a complete
language and our meets that definition
and therefore a lot of the things if you
do have background in computer science
will come very quickly because they're
things that you've seen elsewhere so R
has many operators that you can use to
do math and logical operations and the
overview of those are arithmetic or
mathematic operators logical or boolean
relational operators and assignment
operators and we'll we'll take a quick
look at all those things but just know
that let's say you wanted to launch a
business today and you've just sent up
your cloud service in Amazon Web service
and you're looking for a language that
you're going to be able to quickly
assimilate complex data set R is going
to be a fantastic choice and that's why
Amazon as R as part of its suite of
products that you can actually access in
the
cloud and scale-up at whatever level
your business grows however quickly your
business grows so it's a pretty exciting
thing that you can couple together with
other exciting technology that's out
there the arithmetic operators are you
know you've done them since third grade
these are mathematical operators such as
M plus minus multiply divide
multiplication of course the asterisks
and for exponent we use the caret that's
very commonly used throughout all walks
of science couple things that you may
not have seen are for division with a
remainder we use the modulus which is
two percentage signs and for integer
division we use the /with between the
percentage signs so if you're going to
divide evenly with simply integers you
would use this if you're going to divide
and have a remainder you use the two
percentage sign sir the comparisons in
our relational operators greater than
less than these are things that you
should be very familiar with a couple of
differences in are that are specific to
our are the less than or equal to is a
less than sign with an equal to
following it and the reverse of that for
greater than they're equal to and more
specifically something that's unique to
our is the equals is actually two equal
signs and not equal is the exclamation
point followed by an equal sign so those
are a couple of things that would be
worth keeping in mind
additional logical operators logical not
of course again is an exclamation point
also are as in other languages Python I
believe element wise is how we you know
the most basic
data point in our is an element it's
referred to as an element so a single
character or a number and when you want
to use an illogical and the ampersand
would be used individually to compare
one element with another if you're going
to compare larger sets as in vectors
matrices and so on which we'll get into
in another lesson
then you would use two ampersands and
the same convention follows with the or
so and element wise is a single
ampersand two ampersands is comparing
vectors matrices arrays and so on the
same thing would be the case for an or
where you have a pipe or also known as a
verdict R for the element wise or and
for set was you have two pipes
assignment what does that mean in R
instead of using an equals sign R uses
specifically a less than followed by a
dash to assign variables in you know
whether they be numeric character
factors what have you this is something
that's unique to our again in our
specifically you can use a less than
sign followed by a dash two in this case
assign the number 18 to the variable
which we have called H so and we talked
here about left and right assignment
technically you can reverse this
configuration and do the same thing
although this would be considered poor
style by our style guides if you want to
know what is good form or good good
programming style in R and that's
something that's very important to you
and you'd like to know more about it
google has published a comprehensive
style guide which you can do a quick
Google search
pull that up online as with all other
programming languages our supports
conditional if and nested if statements
if else allows you to test a condition
and execute a command or a block of code
if that conditioner is true and of
course execute an alternative command or
block of golden code if that condition
is false the nested-if allows us to
string that process so that you can have
a range of options if you're tested
condition is false then it defaults to
the next condition and so on so the
conditional statements in arm we're
going to use a quick example here and
I'm going to put this in a bigger
context of your business if you're again
going into Amazon Web service and you
have the next uber or the next Google
and you're scaling up and you're looking
to understand your client base for
instance you may want to go through and
catalog the ages and then do some
analysis on the ages of your your your
core client base in this case we're
going to assign the number 20 to the age
variable that we're describing and then
we're going to use an if statement the
if statement says if the age is greater
than 18 then we're gonna print a major
and for our business model that we're
launching you can even insert payday
major payday if age is greater than 18
else print minor so in this case our is
going to once I've execute the this
assignment and then I execute this if
statement if I then type the word age
and run what will happen is it's going
to print major if I go back and assign
age 17 it's gonna print minor and that's
the basic functionality of the if-else
statement in all languages and that's
that's kind of how it works and this
gives you the actual syntactical
structure of how this is going to look
when you when you execute a block of
code in our simple block of code the
nested-if does the same thing it just
gives you an additional option and you
can actually string this and ifs
together in really probably as many of
those as you want although that's not
something again that's advised in the
style guide but in this case X gets this
is referred to as gets 0 if X is less
than 0 you're going to say negative
number else X is greater than 0 you're
gonna print a positive number else print
0 so this is now giving you a range of 3
choices depending upon the input that
you give are in this if nested if
statement and it's going to either print
negative number positive number or 0
depending upon the value that you come
back with here's another way that you
can use an if-else statement which is a
vectorized form in this case what we've
done is we've assigned this variable a a
combination of these numerix 1 2 3 & 4
that's what the C says is to combine
these numbers 1 2 3 & 4 we then use an
if-else and we divide a by 2 and this
little command here says if a divided by
2 is exactly equal to 0 then you're
going to print even else print odd so
here this when we when we run it it's
gonna take 1 divided by 2 and calculate
if it's 0 2 divided by 2 calculated and
it's gonna print out these results so
it's gonna print out odd even odd even
basically is what you're looking at and
you can see how if you take that and add
that into your toolbox
of language programming that you that
you have available in our you're going
to quickly be able to use this in the
context of a business or a scientific
application that's of interest to you
another option that our gives you that
works kind of like an if statement very
similar is the switch function and we're
going to get more into functions here in
a few minutes but the switch function is
is a way to give you what we refer to as
a controlled branch of if-else
statements so in this case the switch
has the number two two is a reference to
the position within the variables that
you have in the function so in this case
we would with the number two we would
end up printing ball in the second
example color equals green so anytime we
have green we're going to print the word
avocado conversely if we have the word
red we'll end up printing apple so again
this function switch function as a an
alternative if-else control branch
allows you to begin to have some
framework and to be able to program it
you know in a quickly program in a
direction that's of interest to you in
the same way our supports loops in by
the same way I mean the same as you
would expect in any other language such
as Python C Java so on the loops are for
loop while loop and repeat loop and
we've got three basic examples of those
here in this case for the for loop what
we've done is we've assigned this
variable feck VEC gets one through five
and you'll see in a minute we can
actually just take one and then follow
that by a colon
and the number five that would shorten
this up but here we've expanded it out
so that it's
there what we're doing with the for-loop
command that we have here for Val infect
print Val what this is going to do is
it's going to it's going to print out
one two three four five in other words
those are the values in the loop and
when it's done the loop is complete and
has finished executing the while loop is
the same as the for loop but in in this
case it's going to print whatever
numbers that are encountered in the in
the line
while the condition is true so while I
is less than six R is going to print the
numbers that it encounters in this case
what we've done is we've set it up that
I equals one and the while loop says
that while I is less than six print I I
equals I plus one so in the same way
that the for loop executed this is going
to print one through five and then stop
the repeat loop requires that we insert
this break function or else it will
continue to go perpetually so in this
case this works the same as the while
loop repeat print X x equals x plus one
so that's the same as the I plus one and
then if we did not add in this little
clause here it would just continue to
repeat so we have to insert the break
function and that's what this is
describing inside the loop the brake
function stops the iteration and it
forces the flow to jump off of the loop
a next statement allows us to skip a
value so within a loop if there's a
value that you that you want the loop to
exclude or ignore then you can use the
next function so in this case one
through five again for values in number
if it's equal to three
so this is going to print one two four
five in the loop
okay the scan function is one way that
you can access documents or scripts
which is what we call blocks of code are
and read that information into our for
data manipulation and we'll talk in
another lesson about the types of data
that are can read but quickly what we
need to understand here is that scan can
be used on for instance the file path in
this case is a web URL it can be used on
any you know can be used as a file path
within your own directory your home
directory and skin is one way of reading
again data whether it be a script or a
block of text or an Excel or a CSV I
tend to use read rather than scan and
that just seems to work for me best read
dot CSV and then followed by a
parenthesis and the file path works
equivalent you can also use the source
function which will allow you to you if
you put the the path inside the
parentheses here that will allow you to
execute a script at the time that you
run this function so you can say source
put a file path in these parentheses and
a script will execute and here's an
example of how this how this reads if
you're really into running things in the
from a file from a command prompt then
our command batch may be a good option
for you you can pass command-line
arguments to scripts you can get very
creative with uh with batch script
using the the our command batch function
and these are a bunch more functions
just to give you a taste and the nice
thing is these are not fake code items
that you have to go and reinvent they
are already there for you you just have
to use the built-in functions in R such
as help to understand how they work and
what the key parameters and variables
are that that are that are that are
required for each function to execute
properly so I'll go through a couple of
them here we're not going to go through
all of them but there's a couple of them
that are nice of length for instance
will return the length of an object so
if you have a variable or if you have a
matrix then you can put that information
in the parentheses length will will give
you the number of characters identical
tests whether two objects are equal that
would be nice for instance if you had
two data sets and they had varying
weights for instance weighted averages
you could potentially use this function
to make a comparison their list of
objects that's very similar to something
that you would use if you're into using
command prompt programming and app and
actually the first one here append adds
elements to a vector the vector which we
talked about again in another lesson is
the most basic data set in R it's a
group of same elements so for instance
they're all numbers or they're all
factors ie strings character strings and
or logicals they're all logicals they
must be all of the same data type and it
is a one two
in channel dataset so if I had five of
my best friends names John Salley Joe
bill George they I could save as a an
element and then if I forgot that I left
you know Jill out of that said I can use
the append function to add Jill to my
vector quickly and cleanly these are
some other functions again there is a
ton of functions in R and I would
encourage you to get your feet into R as
quickly as you can and experiment and
play with these functions the quicker
you do
the quicker you come up to speed with
you know what they are and how they work
and there's a lot of ways that you'll
you'll be helped by using the help
function that's built into our to
quickly understand it so to lower this
we'll take a whole string of characters
and put it you know take it to lowercase
or uppercase grep as you I'm sure are
familiar with other languages or may not
be but this allows us to search for
patterns and summary this is great
statistical function allows you to get
kind of the core statistical data and
pull it out of a data set and so on Oh
class this tells you the class of you
know of the or the Titan of element that
you're looking at our object that you're
looking at
you